the Joe Rogan experience she definitely
want some attention
yeah but Teflon Donny she can't do that
Teflon Don it is crazy how he's been
able to shake everything off okay
everything if you stand ten tools down
he came out you do not until you that's
why I keep saying like don't worry about
these tech companies stand ten toes down
stand ten toes down
yeah was I mean Stanley if you know
stand on your foot like you know I stand
your ground you know
don't waver just because somebody says
something yeah I get criticized a lot
online in my responses I said what I
said you know how I'll infuriate the
left and I fury ate the right and the
right to feel like well last week you
were pro Trump and now you're saying
something that's different is like and
well you got the most [ __ ] I think for
that Starbucks video the Starks video
was hilarious thank you well you've
walked into Starbucks and you said I
hear you out you guys are racist I'm
here to get my free Starbucks
yeah and that lady was like okay Amanda
shout out to a man shout out to Amanda
she's like yeah I heard that
hold on I'll get your coffee it's like I
didn't know you could just give away
coffee you work at Starbucks but I guess
she just did I manifested death where
was that I was a New Jersey what Barry
commies Martha yeah that's hilarious
yeah but you know like I manifested it
and you can go look at that the tweet
two weeks before said I said uh if you
want to be on mainstream media pretend
to be a liberal then I also said I said
that my followers I said can y'all get
me on Fox News the next week I pulled
this stunt and then got on Fox News now
when they had you on Fox News what was
the premise what were they gonna target
would they say hey it's Wonder story
there's one right this one some is one
of some [ __ ] and they also probably
wanted a little bit of potential outrage
asking for coffee reparations yeah you
got a black guy who's asking for
reparations they kind of like that
especially when it's spoofing the left
so yeah they you know they they kind of
want to weaponize me yeah so yeah
there's a lot of that I thought it was
funny
I told us that were you you're very
friendly about it you know was like you
were being angry anything did you have
your son with you or someone - yeah
the whole family doesn't mean that's
funny man yeah yeah my son didn't he I
told him I go ahead and get free coffee
Yeah right
ah your dad's really about to pull this
off
[Applause]